The proposed definition will hold that
extremism is the promotion or advancement of an ideology
based on violence, hatred
or intolerance that aims to negate or destroy
the fundamental rights and freedoms of others
or undermine, overturn
or replace the UK system of Liberal parliamentary democracy
and democratic rights,
or intentionally create a permissive environment for others.
To achieve these results is important to stress that
we are in no way intending to restrict freedom of expression,
religion or belief, but the government cannot be in a position where,
unwittingly or not, we sponsor,
subsidize or support in any way
organizations and individuals opposed to the freedoms we hold dear.